the power inside le pouvoir de
l'intérieur quand on m'a demandé parler
de ce sujet je me suis rappelé que moi
il m'avait fallu du temps avant de me
rendre compte que j'avais quelque chose
à l'intérieur un pouvoir quelque chose
de spécial qui pouvait changer le monde
le pouvoir c'est quelque chose que l'on
a mais que l'on n'utilise pas forcément
et moi j'ai commencé à utiliser le mien
quand j'étais très jeune du fou pour moi
ça me paraissait quelque chose de banal
de deux classiques mais en fait j'ai
commencé à me rendre compte que c'était
pas si banal que ça quant à chaque fois
que je rencontrais quelqu'un qui me
paraissaient insensible inactif face aux
catastrophes catastrophe aux menaces du
monde et que ça me mettait en colère
ça m'énervait je ne comprenais pas
comment on pouvait ne rien faire alors
qu'il y avait tellement de problèmes à
travers le monde
et du coup finalement cette colère elle
est passée parce que je me suis rendu
compte que c'est pas que les gens face à
moi était insensible non c'est qu'en
fait ils avaient peur parce que ça peut
faire peur quand même de se dire que on
est à l'intérieur de soi une énergie si
puissante qu'elle est capable de
transformer ce qu'il ya autour de nous
de changer notre vie la vie de notre
famille de nos amis voir la vie de
milliers de personnes
ça fait peur mais en même temps moi je
fais partie de ces gens qui ont toujours
pensé que pour apprendre il faut échoué
pour apprendre il faut essayer et du
coup ça m'a jamais vraiment fait peur de
d'échouer ça m'a jamais vraiment fait
peur de tester mes idées et c'est
peut-être pour ça que j'ai réussi à
faire grandir ce pouvoir à l'intérieur
le pouvoir intérieur de chacun
finalement quand on additionne au sein
d'une communauté du
d'un gouvernorat d'un pays ben ça peut
donner quelque chose de très fort parce
qu'une communauté
c'est la somme des individus c'est la
somme des pouvoir activer ou inactive et
et communauté de communautés 50
communautés ensemble elles sont capables
de tirer un pays en entier vers le haut
au contraire vers le bas moi quand je
suis arrivé en tunisie en 2012 j'avais
24 ans j'étais assez naïve je savais pas
vraiment j'avais quelque chose de
spécial je savais juste que j'avais
cette énergie cette volonté de faire
quelque chose pas quelque chose de très
grand mais quelque chose qui pourrait
changer la vie de quelques personnes
autour de moi je suis parti m'installer
à birsa l'a 47 km au nord de sacs sur la
gp11 chez mes grands-parents quittant
paris ma mère se ma famille française en
bretagne pour démarrer quelque chose de
nouveau
alors forcément tout le monde m'a dit
mais tu es complètement folle mais
qu'est ce que tu fais mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
mais moi j'avais cette énergie à
l'intérieur cette chose qui me poussait
qui me disaient non vas-y sarah tu as
quelque chose à faire tu dois
l'accomplir et de coûts en 2012 je me
suis mise à dans la tête un projet de
planter des acacias pour lutter contre
la désertification la pauvreté et
l'inégalité des genres dans le village
de mes grands parents à bir salle alors
vous imaginez bien que quand je suis
arrivé là bas
john may 24 ans de paris pleine
d'énergie
on va changer le monde va améliorer tout
on va changer vers salle tout va
s'améliorer et tout le monde va regarder
un peu bizarrement crémazie vent
maxicheque votre calme et riche benti
c'est pas comme c'est pas si facile que
ça dans ce pays mais je ne suis pas
démotivé premier échec
on lance la pépinière las casas for all
relance les plantations d'acacias et
puis alors que tout le monde était
motivé d'un seul coup on me dit non en
fait ça m'intéresse plus comment je vais
gagner d'argent mois avec ça après tout
et puis je vais planter des acacias là
et puis ça va me coûter beaucoup
d'argent doerig et de mettre de l'eau
non non non ça m'intéresse q mais je ne
suis pas découragé et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des personnes derrière moi pour
me pousser
parce qu'en fait en fait ce que je me
suis rendu compte c'est quand on a cette
énergie à l'intérieur qui nous pousse et
ben général on trouve toujours les
personnes les bonnes personnes au bon
moment de notre vie quand on se dit ça y
est je vais quitter je m'en vais j'en ai
marre qui vous remettre sur le droit
chemin
et moi j'ai eu la chance en 2013 valade
avoir des personnes qui m'ont aidé et
qui m'ont poussé et qui m'ont aidé aussi
à re motiver les gens de birsa la
rénovant l'école dispensaires etc et on
est reparti et on a créé une pépinière
encore plus grande j'ai essayé de
mobiliser encore plus de monde et on a
planté 50 milliards en 2014
ouah
mais c'était pas assez parce qu avait
toujours des gens qui se plaignait y
avait toujours qui disent aux gens qui
disaient oui mais bon au final moi ça me
sert à quoi tout ça me sert à quoi tout
ce que tu fais moi ce que je veux c'est
du travail c'est de l'argent s'est
amélioré ma vie et puis tous ces jeunes
avec qui je vivais au quotidien ses
filles avec des diplômes de maîtrise des
masters qui avait rien à faire il
fallait bien leur trouver quelque chose
à faire il fallait bien les motiver du
coup on s'est lancé un challenge encore
plus fous on s'est dit ok vous voulez de
l'ambition vous allez avoir de
l'ambition on va te vanter un million
d'arbres en tunisie pas seulement à
birsa là alors évidemment tout le monde
m'a pris pour une folle comme d'habitude
mais je ne me suis pas laissé abattre et
j'ai eu la chance de on parle de pouvoir
intérieur
moi j'ai lancé cet appel comme ça j'ai
dit voilà mesdames et messieurs la
tunisie moi je veux qu'on plante
ensemble un million d'arbres si ça vous
intéresse à faisons ça ensemble et il
fait plein de gens qui ont répondu à
l'appel en fait est hors du coup là on
en est on s'y retrouvait à planter
ensemble en un an et demi plus de 300
mille arbres et du coup 300 milliards et
nous en reste aujourd'hui cette forme il
a planté et il ya quelques mois
là des gens qui m'ont dit oui bon sahara
c'était sympa c'est bien de rêver tous
annoncés bien ta plante et 3,5 milles
c'est bien déjà ces fonds arrête maman
fait quelque chose d'intéressant ta vie
tu vas jamais réussir à trouver des 700
milliards d'ici la fin 2010 8 es tu vas
jamais réussir à les planter
mais comme je dis toujours il ya
toujours moi je crois beaucoup à la
chance et à la sérendipité
mais on a fini par là les trouver les
sept cent mille arbres et celle là on va
aller planter d'ici la fin de l'année
avec vous et plein d'autres gens en
tunisie
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis sur scène aujourd'hui et
vous vous devez vous pensez wallah plein
d'énergie positive
sa vie est super elle a de la chance de
faire ce qu'elle aime en réalité ma vie
elle est pas toujours aussi simple elle
est même assez compliqué c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile de décider de porter
ses rêves et de décider de transformer
un rêve en réalité
surtout quand c'est pas un rêve
individuelle mais que c'est un rêve
collectif
mon association je les appelais jam in
tunisia l'omt own site
avec cette idée qu'ensemble on est
capable de transformer le pays justement
à travers ces énergies positives parce
que je crois vraiment que c'est chacun
ensemble on associe nos énergies
on est capable de transformer
complètement notre pays et que le
potentiel est tellement énorme qu'on
fait on n'a pas le droit d'abandonner
même si la situation en ce moment elle
est assez pessimiste et que je sais que
beaucoup veulent partir mais moi j'y ai
pensé mais moi j'ai pensé à repartir
l'année dernière quand j'ai eu
énormément de problèmes
l'année dernière je me suis dit c'est
bon mais sarah qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de faire et finalement est ce que
la tunisie a vraiment besoin de ça est
ce que les gens avec qui tu travailles
ont vraiment besoin de ces arbres que tu
plantes et ce qu'ils ont vraiment besoin
de tes idées et ce qu'ils ont vraiment
besoin de ton énergie est ce que tu es
pas en fait en train de faire plus de
mal que de bien
et c'est vrai que je suis vraiment posé
la question de cette énergie qu'on a à
l'intérieur
comment on fait pour qu'elle reste
positive moi j'adore la saga star wars
dans la saga star wars on dit que les
jedi
ils ont
c'est les chevaliers du bien en fait ils
ont le bien mais parfois un jedi peut se
transformer en dark vador et peut
devenir le mal et comment on fait en
fait pour garder toujours cette
sincérité
cette humilité et ce tout cet amour de
ce qu'on fait alors au moment où
vraiment j'étais au plus bas l'année
dernière j'étais vraiment dans une
situation jugée j'arrête ou je repars à
paris je fais un travail normal de jean
normal j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone de
l'elysée on m'a dit madame to me voilà
vous avez été choisi par le président la
république française pour le conseiller
sur les questions d'agriculture et de
climat en afrique
alors je dis très drôle
non non non moi c'est fini j'arrête ou
non on m'a dit non non non vraiment on
est très sérieux venait à paris on va
tout vous expliquer alors au début j'ai
cru que ses blagues
non mais bon il y avait cette petite
chose dans ma tête j'ai dit non mais si
ce n'était pas une blague
si jamais vraiment il y avait des gens
qui croient en ses idées et qui encore
mieux vaut les propulser à l'échelle de
l'afrique et je suis parti à paris
j'ai rencontré le président macro et la
première chose qui m'a dit sarah merci
beaucoup
alors je
ça fait un mois en tunisie à birsa là
les gens en général disent pas merci
yonne
merci beaucoup de nous donner l'espoir
de nous montrer jeunesse arabe
tunisienne africaine qui va contre le
statu quo et qui avance et qui montre
une image positive
sarah je veux que vous me conseiller sur
comment on peut construire ensemble une
nouvelle relation entre la france et les
pays africains et comment la france peut
soutenir l'agriculture et surtout
l'adaptation au changement climatique
comment on peut repenser les choses et
voilà je me suis retrouvée de jallet
tout abandonner à ma maintenant à
travailler sur dix pays d'afrique
saharienne sur ce que j'adorais faire à
birsa là mais à plus grande échelle
[Applaudissements]
et tout ça pour dire qu'en fait mon
parcours il est c'est le parcours de
beaucoup de personnes qui croient en
leurs rêves et qui pique nique qui
avance en fait qui qui se laisse pas
arrêter par les malheurs de la vie qui
utilise en fait donc pour moi je
considère que tout ce qui arrive dans ma
vie est positif bien comme mauvais
d'ailleurs je suis plein de gratitude
pour toutes les personnes qui m'ont
toujours mis des bâtons dans les roues
depuis que j'ai commencé mon projet que
ça soit les gens qui m'ont envoyé le
service des impôts chaque mois où la
cnss ou qui voulait me mettre en prison
parce qu'ils pensaient que j'allais
détruire les oliveraies de saxe tous ces
personnels doit contribuer en fait à
m'aider à m'améliorer moi en tant qu' en
tant que personne
en tant que qu'actrice du changement et
finalement la gratitude je crois que
c'est le plus important en fait pour
cultiver cette énergie qu'on a à
l'intérieur toujours avoir ce sentiment
de d'avoir la chance d'être privilégié
d'avoir la chance d'avoir des personnes
autour de soi qui qui qui vraiment
s'intéressent à ce qu'on fait que ça
soit positivement ou négativement et du
coup moi la seule chose que j'ai envie
de vous dire aujourd'hui c'est ben nous
on va se lancer là d'ici quelques
semaines dans la plantation de 700 mille
arbres restants avec une application
mobile qui s'appelle wang min chine sort
tunisia on a prévu d'en planter 200
milles à sfax est en fait si chacun de
nous ici dans la salle plantée déjà même
un arbre sans frais déjà ses 150
alors moi cette énergie je lai est
planté sept cent mille ha je crois que
même si je le fais pas même si je dois
le faire tout seul un jour c'est pas
grave j'ai que trente ans xala j'aurai à
les 50 ans de plus pour le faire mais je
crois vraiment que tous ensemble si on
s'associe si on salit on est capable
certes de planté sept cent mille arbres
mais c'est pas que planter des arbres
c'est vraiment montrer qu'on est
capables de travailler ensemble qu'on
est capable main dans la main en fait
d'atteindre un objectif commun qui
dépassent un intérêt personnel
un objectif commun qui montre qu'en fait
on est tous unis pour améliorer notre
quotidien en tunisie que même si c'est
dur ensemble on croit que on se fait
assez confiance pour essayer de changer
un petit peu les choses
et du coup voilà nos chez jimmy
tunisiens on pense que un homme rêve
seul et ce n'est qu'un rêve
mais dès lors que tous ensemble on se
met à rêver ensemble alors c'est le
début de la réalité voilà merci
[Applaudissements]